proponent of itself I'd like to call
them up and out unless claddagh has
another idea i'll call them up in the
order in which i have them and the first
speaker on my list this afternoon is my
colleague Molina Gomez who will talk to
us about the Colombian you ready her
line' about the colombian they asked for
a community welcome good afternoon first
I'd like to thank Clara for inviting me
to participate in this conference on
international Latin American isms I'm
actually thrilled to be here today
because I'm a product of the urban
planning ph.d program here so I'm
homegrown and I spent several years ago
many times back there taking notes
during classes so it's a thrill to be
here actually on the podium for today I
wanted to go through for discussion
points to share with you a lot of the
work that I did in my dissertation to
start out I want to give you an
introduction on how I encountered the
issue of remittances and housing
investments in Colombia second give you
a snapshot of importance of remittances
in Colombia give you a snapshot of the
importance of remittances in Colombia
and the story behind remittances and
housing invest with second i want to
share a few of the findings the key
findings of my dissertation regarding
housing investments and how remittances
and housing investments have impacted
public policy go long last I've been
working on this topic for about four
years I wanted to share some ideas that
i have on remittances housing
in Colombian transnationalism I first
heard of remittances in 2003 and I have
a confession to make i had no idea what
it was but I wasn't alone because in
Colombia very little research has been
done in remittances we had no idea who
was sending the money back home we had
no idea what the money was where the
money was going to so all we knew back
then was that million billions of
dollars were being channeled back home
with little information of what was
going on in the in the business market
so in 2004 when sefa asked me to teach a
an MPA public workshop I decided that be
really interesting to structure my
course on trying to understand the
remittance industry in queens in Jackson
Heights Queens so after the course I
realized that um I was totally
captivated hooked on the issue of
remittances but I had a second problem
was that I wanted to study the issue of
remittances for my PhD but I could just
tell that my faculty would say what are
the planning application so I struggled
with that until the fall of 2004 the
Colombian there was a Colombian housing
fair that took place in New York in the
fall of 2004 and that's when I decided
how interesting i can connect
remittances to something related to my
dissertation so i noticed in the housing
fair that there was a lot of excitement
and a buzz among the immigrant community
of buying a home everybody was talking
about all I can buy a home back home
something new that hadn't been discussed
ten years ago and at the same time I
noticed the same excitement with
construction companies and banks trying
to reach out to the immigrant market but
they hadn't really thought that it
existed so they I somehow saw this the
interest of the businessmen in Colombia
like though in the past years the
treasure-seekers looking for guac guys
in Indian tombs all of a sudden they
thought oh those wat guys might be
abroad in
communities in Europe in the u.s. so
then I got you know I decided this would
be an interesting topic to follow
because very little knowledge was known
in this field this was 2004 and there
was much to be learned i had to learn
and also the government in the
construction and business companies had
a lot to learn for example there were no
procedures the government hadn't set up
any procedures to send money legally to
columbia for the purchase of real estate
banks didn't know how to offer credit to
immigrants how to offer mortgages so
there was a learning process that we all
had to go through I remember in the
housing fair 2004 I bumped into a
student of mine from Columbia and she
showed me two checks she said milena I
have two checks I don't know what to do
with them can i deposit them in my bank
account or will I be accused of money
laundering nobody knew so it was until
January of 2005 like Colombian
government said I set up an account
number 18 12 within the bounds of camp
balance of payments to send money
legally from abroad to Colombia um so
that's why i say 2004 was a turning
point it was a turning point for me and
it was a turning point for the research
that was generating everybody realized
there are millions of dollars billions
of dollars coming into the country and
nobody knew what was going on 2004
there's a influx of research articles in
the newspaper journals in bank Oladipo
ligas our journals such as report
officially me sort and then Socorro mica
articles in portfolio semana everybody
talking about remittances and maybe of
the dream of having obscene or making
them productive in addition in 2004 five
surveys were commissioned we're on the
next slide oh it's me
okay so 2004 there were five surveys
commissioned to buy the international
migration organization together they
partner with Colombian organizations
Colombian government organizations like
the diamond at the foreign ministry one
done by face at royo an economic think
tank at lycée a radio station from
Colombia interviewed immigrants in
Florida to find out what they were
thinking and ben dixon associates
associates made a survey of Colombians
as they've done with other countries in
Latin American presented the findings in
IDP sponsored conference in the fall of
two thousand four in Cartagena so there
was still a lot of buzz in 2004
regarding trying to figure out what was
going on in this market regarding my
research on remittance I spent from 2004
2 2008 trying to figure out what's going
on with the housing market so I not only
reviewed all the literature on what was
being written back then but I
interviewed public policy decision
makers I attended five of the 15 fairs
that took place in New York New Jersey
Miami mother didn't London and I also
did a lot of work on the internet just
to give you an idea over 80 construction
companies have participated in these
fairs and I reviewed what they were
selling and also followed the nose from
gamma core the housing construction law
bringing Luke and so in five years we
have some information that helps us
figure out what was going on in this
market to give you an idea before talk
about these were the pictures I took
from the fair in 2005 and 2006 as you
can see back then there were lines of
Colombians trying to get into the fair
they were very crowded by friend they've
lesson since then and this was an idea
snapshot I took of the you know there
/ reaches these were the photos taken in
the end yoga region but you find that
for every region in Colombia so a big a
little snapshot of the importance of
remittances in Colombia in 2008 4.8
billion dollars were sent to Colombia
were this second largest flow after
Mexico and Brazil and just to point out
in 2008 the remittances continued to
increase to Colombia even though the
news were showing that remains is had to
crease in other countries of Latin
America remittances in Colombia count
for two percent of the gdp which is much
lower than other countries we heard from
this more this afternoon in a previous
comment that it side by Lauren on dudas
receives their GDP thereby over ten
percent of their gdp depends on
remittances Columbia doesn't really
depend on the remittances as much as
other Central American Latin American
countries we're still talking about a
very important flow it's second to oil
imports and derivatives in the export
I'll show you a graphing in a few
moments and more than thirty six percent
of the flows come from the United States
which differentiates the Colombian case
from the Mexican case the following
chart shows the increase in remittances
over the years and before you ask me why
the increase was so dramatic after 19 99
and 2000 I think I'd like to explain why
I probably shouldn't have included the
information prior to nineteen ninety
nine because it's a bit hypothetical
because in Colombia at that time there
were strict controls of foreign exchange
so all the money being chained in
exchange was done in the black market so
it didn't go through the regular
channels of the legal channels I 2000 or
1999-2000 thing changed the bank we love
I believe got a sentra
Bank included new forms of book you've
been imposed new forms of bookkeeping
las casas de cambio which are the money
exchange offices fell under more
scrutiny to the superintendent john
caria so they made any transaction of
over five hundred dollars you had to you
know legally declare it so of course
there was more money being accounted for
but more importantly is that dollars
became legal in Colombia you didn't have
to rely on the black market you can open
an account in dollars in the bank and
exchange dollars and obviously the
numbers went up last and not but not
least in 1998 to 1999-2000 there was an
enormous exodus of Colombians leaving
the country and that what they were
leaving because of security issues in
the economy and so they of course we're
sending remittances back home so that
explains the the steady increase from
2000 onwards with respect to exports as
you can see the line the yellow line
shows the money coming in for
remittances it's three times the value
of coffee the traditional Colombian
expert product and obviously not as high
as oil import it oil exports and its
derivatives now this is a graph that
shows the money coming in legally by way
of the account 1812 for purchases of
real estate so my point is that it's
you're seeing a general trying to steady
trend going upwards maybe going a little
bit downwards in the past couple of
months but that's probably caused by the
recession this that the quantities
coming in legally through account 1814
represent four percent of the total
volume of remittances in Colombia but
that doesn't account for the money that
family sent through the regular
remittance China channels that according
to the surveys and studies that have but
have been done to date represent four
five percent so we're actually talking
about eight or nine percent of all the
remittance flows going into housing
investments okay these are three of the
main findings of my dissertation and
this shows basically why the Colombian
taste is different or unique from others
first of all from all the surveys done
to date it shows the remittances are
urban affair in Colombia the money being
sent abroad goes to urban regions in
Colombia because the immigrants come
from urgent urban regions obviously
logistically this money if you're gonna
if you're coming from an urban region
you're going to buy a home in an urban
region so it reveals at ninety-five
percent of all the homes sold in
Colombia are in the main cities
basically whoa whoa doc gallium a game
but also in a mania Byron kiya kartay
hain and parada a second interesting
finding is that most of the homes being
or the money being channeled through the
account 1812 goes directly for new
housing and that sort of depends on the
type of the type of businesses only new
housings are sold in affairs and only
new housing or sold in the Internet so
if you're an immigrant in new jersey and
you want to buy a home by home while you
go to the fair you see new homes and for
you then you check it on the internet so
use property and home improvements are
not really in the market so I have a map
to show you which shows this the
offering of sales in the bowl of that in
the cab of the Columbia and it basically
shows that immigrants are buying
property where the new developments are
springing up so it just do the cells of
property mirror urban development in
Colombia in Bogota in the main cities
this map shows the stratification the
type of homes that are being sold
the yellow shows expensive property is
that those sequences you know the hive
expensive property and you can say that
there's not much of an offering for
expensive property the red reveals nice
housing you getting that associated
which is low income housing which is
also not really in the market for
immigrants immigrants are really buying
into a stat 2 3 & 4 which are the
mid-level prices a cost of an apartment
or a home in this type of 3 and four
would be actually around 40 to 55
thousand dollars those are the that's
the niche that's the price that
apartments are selling and I mentioned
many of you will be asking me well you
know what type of home can you buy for
that money here in New York you could
probably renovate your bathroom with
that money but you wouldn't be able to
buy anything in Colombia with 50000
dollars you can buy a nice two bedroom
apartment in the middle class
neighborhood so that's you know that's
part of the success and that's also true
for apartments and Hounds being sold in
Bangladesh in the Philippines money goes
a lot more in these countries been here
this is I just thought this is a typical
apartment that gets sold to immigrants
living here it's a nice nice
construction these are the type of homes
that are sold in the fairs you know
people here dream of having that home
home they can probably never be able to
afford that here in the state but i just
wanted to show it because i saw it in
the fair and this one which is a condo
in Cartagena was shown in the fairs and
actually I said oh I'd love that but
Connie time so but you know four hundred
thousand dollars you can have your dream
home and got behind and some people some
people made money and they could really
afford it but I just it impacted me so I
wanted to share it with you so now how
the whole process of
remittances and housing investments have
impacted public policy I think the most
important impact that remittances have
had on government is that it's
reconnected the state to immigrants
before the video a government immigrants
were ignored by public policy makers I
for my dissertation I reviewed all the
memoirs of the foreign ministers that
were sent to the Congress since the
seventies and only two talked about the
importance of reaching at the immigrants
most of them are all of them talked when
they talked about the work of the
Consulate's they were talking about how
many passports were sold the visas sold
authentications in certificate and the
efficiency was measured on the number of
passwords old but no mention was made
about reaching that to the immigrants
living in Spain in the States or you
know or laska whatever so so this is a
big it has been a big change you leave a
government adopted because of
remittances I think adopted reaching out
to America to immigrants as one of its
important goals and they started the
Columbia knows own a program and in the
Colombian asuna program one of the basic
programs is selling homes immigrants and
I think that's a key that why this
program has been successful after two
minutes left why it's been successful is
because the government has supported the
fairs and it's also supported not just
with participating in affairs but just
president would even the ministers go to
affairs I went to one in 2005 in
president who leave it was there he had
walked status among the colombian
immigrants here and he kept on asking
the fair who's going to buy your house
and everybody would I hide me Presidente
I will I well so so that type of
supported with the seal of government
approval helped jumpstart this whole
process the housing industry is also
it's also vital for the development
programs of the government so selling
homes is a good business for the
government because employment provides
employment five or six percent of all
employment Columbia depends on how the
construction business it gives economic
opportunities and it's up provides it
helps out with the quantitative and
qualitative deficits in the housing
stock in Columbia ah ok so to conclude I
would say that research that they should
suggest that there exists a healthy
demand about immigrants to invest in
this real estate back home it's not a
huge amount we're talking about two
hundred dollars a year but it's an
accomplishment and if you add up all the
money that has been sent since the
account was started it's over 744
million dollars which is it's it's money
that wouldn't have been there if they
hadn't stirred it the whole process of
selling homes back home there's a quote
from guate nice or professor gardeny so
that mentions that remittances are
definitely a symbol of transnational
behavior and I just wanted to add and
take his remarks a step further and just
basically say that not only sending
remittances but invest in them in a home
back home is demonstrating even tighter
bonds transnational bonds with your
hundreds you're putting money you're
investing you know even in any amount is
a huge investment so real estate
investments are an important indicator
for transnational in life I'm suggesting
that investment real estate will score
higher on the transnational litmus test
then find a telephone card and calling
or visiting your grandmother on on
holidays or eating an idea when you're
in Connecticut so it's just because
money talks and I think showing a big
investment represents that you're
interested in remaining connected to
Colombia or to your country of origin
and lastly I
like to say that immigrants come to
American search of the American Dream
and now i think this definition of the
american dream i would incorporate that
part of the American Dream is including
a home back home it's a new way of
seeing the American Dream and also
because it's becoming for immigrants
nowadays it's becoming very difficult to
find the American Dream here so it's
easier to find it with a home back home
and this is true from the research I've
done not just for immigrants wanting to
buying Kallio adventitia but also in
Bangladesh in the Philippines you talk
to anybody everybody dreams of having a
home back home and lastly I would just
say that the government's participation
in this whole business has been
successful and they basically prospered
from incorporating immigrants into their
national public policy thank you thank
you very very much media and I was
extremely enthusiastic with your paper
and North your description such
beautiful homes available for 50,000 but
then you said the one that i won
Cartagena's $100,000 saw a little bait
and switch there but we look forward in
the Q&A in the discussion with medium to
look at sort of what you've given us a
case day of the housing industry but
sort of the broader linkages between the
aspera communities and their home and
that kind of sort of trans nationalism
that results there as we've seen a
glimpse of it through the housing market
but has broader linkages and broader
dimensions that maybe we can discuss so
thank you very much milena I went
against I had an older format so on a
Warren the authors I want to go back to
the authorised format an order in which
you're speaking give moment that catch
your breath but I I would like now to
read I'm going to be calling media and
she own up now medium
if you would median you've got her bio
in our program she has her doctor degree
in city and regional planning from
Berkeley if you've read her paper which
I assume you have on spaces of
multiplicity in cosmopolitan Cusco you
would have thought her degree was in
anthropology but so far so she is a very
multidisciplinary person her bio says
she is an assistant professor of
international development and community
environment at Clark in Massachusetts
but I believe you've changed since then
and our back in working in city planning
in in san francisco in any case i
welcome you and look forward to your
paper when i started it is a pleasure to
be here with you today and I want to
approach the framework of transnational
Latin Latin American isms through the
construction the production of spaces of
multiplicity in cosmopolitan cuzco i
want to explain and explore how not just
the resources and the multiple influx of
people from all over the world intersect
but also some of the cultural forms that
lead to very specific construction of
places and as Clara indicated earlier
today this is an intellectual inquiry
but it's also a political statement in
terms of the types of development the
path of developments that one can pursue
in this context of transnational Latin
Latin Latin American ism I am with the
association of Bay Area governments
right now enacting my own
transnationalism in other words bringing
the knowledge of cusco peru to inform
some of the planning processes in san
francisco i would like to first go and
give you a quick overview of some of
that ongoing development trends in the
city of cusco
then I review some of the reason the
reason conceptions of cosmopolitanism to
then rethink how we can approach the
concept of routed cosmopolitanism to
understand what's happening in Cusco and
what are some of the development options
that can open up in terms of KU + as you
already know who's good is located in
the southern highlands of Peru it it's a
regional forum was had the shape of the
original Inca city with the head defined
by the fortress of saksaywaman and the
body shaped by two creeks sup Ian to you
my you it is a city that carries it's
located in a valley and it has expanded
along the valley and as you can see
towards the mountains as well it carries
a very important history as the capital
of the Inca civilization that is
expressed on the walls on the streets it
also represents a major place for some
of the colonial architectures through
the churches & places but even more
interesting is how that history is
carried through some of the ongoing
cultural activities dance music
festivals as well as the way the bread
is made or sold or exchanged now because
of this heritage Cusco has been an
important place of tourist activity it's
not new it's been at least in place in
this more or less current modern form
for a century but what it's very
dramatic as the growth that the city has
experienced in the last 20 to 30 years
and I'm taking a very low point of
during a period of economic decline but
even in the last ten years the number of
tourists per year have increased and one
important point to recognize here is the
way in which some some of this tourist
growth took place how it was shaped by
the work
the local the municipal government right
before this rapid expansion so beyond
the scale of the growth of tourism
what's what's also important to
understand is how this tourism is
unfolding in the city for the first time
the city allow the opening of that
McDonald's in the main plaza it's not
that is the first fast-food outlet
international franchise very upscale
organic restaurant and expensive hotels
this is a ten monastery or class and
after Dana's completely renovated the
rooms are here are the most effective
expensive one go up to nineteen hundred
dollars per night per room yeah so you
go throughout their wide range you can
buy an apartment in in Cartagena for a
few nights of this hotel the chapel
again that has been fully renovated is
now used as a you know space for
business meetings and conventions and so
the whole setting in terms of the the
lifestyle has acquired a different a
different dimension now because of the
growth in tourism which is not unique to
cusco i'm sure you know across all our
places were seeing that but it's just
that in cusco it gets amplified the
trends are unqualified one of the
concepts that being that people have
been playing around that we scholars
have been playing around is the concept
of cosmopolitanism is that a concept
that can help us understand some of the
ongoing trends not just in Paris or New
York but also in places like cuzco that
as you can see cover a really wide
spectrum of places and activities
in in exploring there there's a common
sense of what we mean by cosmopolitanism
is some exposure beyond your own home
boundaries some understanding of
cultural diversity but there are some
specific concerns that come with this
form of production or Disqus if a'
concept and they have been collide by
various scholars the elitism that is
produced as cosmopolitanism is produced
by or is led by a traveling class with a
high level of resources the
commodification of activities and places
so that those are acquired and exchange
value that is detached from their
specific realities if you find a girl
with a yama at the city of cusco that is
created for the tourists to capture a
picture that has a particular value not
that it relates to the life of that
child in terms of homogenization some of
the level of comfort that we pursue as
we travel whether it is a fast food
outlets like mcdonald or whether it's a
certain type of wine or a certain type
of salmon and sushi that you expect that
a hotel whether you are in cuzco in
beijing or in new york so that kind of
homogenization that makes places more
alike and secures a level of comfort for
this cosmopolitan population now there's
a slightly different uptake on
cosmopolitanism this term rooted
cosmopolitanism apparently an oxime earn
what kind by appt in 1997 and he
attempts to reconcile or at least to
connect some of the local realities with
the global flows and he proposes to
frame this process of routed
cosmopolitanism as one that has local
roots but engages in global flows and as
an experience where one can take
pleasure from the
presence of the other at home one very
important point excuse me that he
recognizes is that we can recognize the
other as different but at the same level
of power which is an important point to
understand the construction of some of
those places like cuzco however it lacks
the specificity to understand how does
this actually happen on the ground how
do you recognize it when you see it or
how you build it if you choose to do so
and for that we I go into the concept of
spatial multiplicity proposed by Massey
a geographer and this concept help us
recognize some of the dimensions that
then can gives us some more grounding in
the construction of places like Cusco so
on one hand there's a recognition of the
coexistence of cultures and identities
we don't have to fragment or one doesn't
have to come in sequence after the other
they coexist in the same place the
second point about the collective
production of places that form relations
and relation is crucial to the
construction of places that is the focus
about how one can recognize space beyond
the immediate territoriality which is
the main point of what we're trying to
articulate here and the understanding
that spaces are dynamic our dynamic are
always under construction we cannot
separate a particular territory and
detach that from the ongoing processes
that are transforming that the place
itself so by taking this this this
spaces of multiplicity and layering with
the rooted cosmopolitanism I want to
explain or elaborate how that how that
takes place in the city of Cusco and
here are some of the some of the
specific points and I'm raising really
came out out of our
conversations and dialogues with with a
wide range of factors in Cuzco through a
community development studio that I run
a couple of years ago and in particular
with one of the doctoral students
Marilyn who really informed the
construction of some of these ideas so
there are three specific points that I
take can help us understand how this
rooted cosmopolitanism is produced in
the city of Cuzco and how these are
choices that can be made a value on
statics openness and spatial commitment
so I'm going to take you to a few cases
that illustrate how that unfolds in the
ceiling in terms of the arts and crafts
the the city of course was well known as
I was saying for some of the crafts that
they produce there are this religious in
figures with the long necks that evoke
the Yama's and alpacas that belonged to
the Andean region maestro lava does the
only survivor of his generation creates
this baby Jesus with an ornament that is
very typical of the goose Canyon
tradition and this this artisans produce
at this point for by commission for
museums across the globe originally it
was for local consumption for part of
the religious festivities but they
produce at a whole different scale here
we have cosas Tina so in terms of
weavings and textiles this is a woman
that not only takes pride in the end
kind of sharing or selling her products
but showing how they are produced to
some of the visitors and explaining the
meaning of some of the designs and even
one step further her sister-in-law has
opened the shops one in cusco and one in
New Haven Connecticut very close by if
you're interested in checking it out and
they run this ongoing workshops to
rescue some of the tradition
that are at risk of being lost through
more kind of industrialized forms of
production but also to kind of recognize
the importance of some of the symbols
and and the qualities of the production
process in terms of the openness I want
to show you a little bit the qualities
of the place the openness of some of the
spatial practices through some of the
drinking activity in the area this is
drinking is an old tradition in the
region it's nothing that has been
imported it's it's ingrained and the
Cascadia culture there are the cheat
ideas and if you can see that little red
flag that indicates when the place still
has teacher deserve and that's a
fermented corn drink that is served in
large glasses in milk in most cases very
simple places in some cases is
accompanied by a spicy food and in most
cases is a company with all kinds of
music now in recent times in recent
years there has been a proliferation of
different callings of eating and
drinking places and you can see you've
got we go from a sushi bar to this
middle eastern place to North American
places to this Cuban bar to this French
club to some of the quite popular Irish
pubs and this is a new layer but it is a
new layer that has been nurtured or open
up by a couple of places that have been
a couple of parts that were in place in
the city for about 30 or 40 years and
let Dalia was a bar opened by John or
John Seto as they call it locally in the
in the 70s as a place of gathering for
locals and foreigners alike as a place
of just entertainment intellectual
exchange political organizing and so
this kind of form the the fact that this
X peace corps volunteer created a space
where there was some mingling beyond the
transaction create a different form of
nighttime entertainment now even more
dramatic is the case of Macondo and the
fallen angel those are places that were
open by andre suniga acous Kenya who's
who was trained and educated in Europe
spent quite a bit of time and in spite
of all kinds of family advice he decided
to return to Cusco and became openly gay
and I I wanted to create the squier
places places that are respectful of all
people but in particular of queer
population which in a city like Cusco
with a very strong religious catholic
sentiment is quite a bit of attention
but here we find something that is not
this does not belong to an international
franchise this is not even something
opened by a foreigner is open by a
casino but a casino that has captured
all kinds of influences and recognizing
different dimensions of his own
experience and the place he's an artist
and paste a lot of attention to the
artwork in those places and the details
and the ways in which the workers relate
to the customers so the point here again
is to understand the openness that comes
from the locals as well as the
foreigners and the intersections that
take place now one very specific and
getting more into kind of the physical
construction of the place the spatial
commitment I want to show you the case
of a cafe in a neighborhood and by
spatial commitment I don't mean a
particular object that is fixed in time
a fortress an archaeological site but
how they collected engages and
appreciates the qualities of a
particular place because of its content
because of its meaning
as you know classes are very important
throughout Latin America and beyond for
all kinds of special festivals but as
well as part of the everyday life we
have heard about that a little bit and
this is the main plaza you have the
cathedral in front and next to the
cathedral there's a small building with
that cafe that it has been or it was
very important to the everyday life of
of couse Canio's and foreigners as well
cafe I you very simple caffeine there's
nothing special as you can see these are
the two workers and they serve all kinds
of hot drinks and pastries this building
owned by the Archdiocese of Cusco was
the starbucks came with a proposal to
pay a higher end they were current they
were paying three thousand dollars per
month which is a lot of money again if
we just look at that in context given
the proposal starbucks the archdiocese
for ten thousand dollars and ten percent
of the business revenues which was way
beyond what this kind of small operation
could afford with all the support that
it has so there was an immediate threat
of displacement that trigger a major
international campaign there was this
campaign save the cafe I you and this is
just one of the pages where this was
done that conveys the sentiment of
people across across the globe from Asia
to Europe to South America to North
America sending a message that this
should not be allowed unfortunately the
cafe was closed a few months ago
fortunately got relocated a few blocks
from where he was and Starbucks has not
been able to open there have been
several serious threats about physical
violence and remains to be seen what
happens with that place just quickly
varios and blass is as one of the
neighborhoods with narrow streets that
has retained a lot of the architecture
this was one of the places that received
major investments from the local
government for remodeling the streets
some of the public spaces lighting
houses that got renovated and of course
that kind of expanded or feel some of
the tourist activities travel agencies
souvenir shops what's interesting about
this neighborhood in spite of some some
of the displacement that is going on
given the increase in property values as
people I'll take over some of these
properties that still retain some of the
local elements the grocery store the
neighborhood oven where people can bring
their goods to be big the street vendors
or the time I laid at the corner that
are enjoyed by locals and foreigners
alike and you can see for example even
in this building that is crumbling on
one side a souvenir shop and on the
other side just a clothesline you know
from a family that just finished the
laundry so what's interesting about this
place is the ability of rate the ability
of locals residents and when we when I
say residents is not just who's canyons
of five generations or ten generations
now residents in some Bloods includes
people that has just arrived to the city
of Cusco whether from South Africa or
from Chile from Argentina from Lima they
have appropriated the place and they
care about the character of the
neighborhood and retaining some of the
qualities as well as nonprofit
organizations as well as the local
government and there's a concerted
effort to try to retain some of the
qualities and amplify some of the
elements that they cherish about this
neighborhood so concluding there are the
three forms of spatial practices valuing
on statics openness and spatial
commitment that I'm proposing to
understand the construction the
production of rooted cosmopolitanism in
Cusco and this production of rooted
cosmopolitanism is it's one dimension of
the growth of tourism
which is no going to stop at least not
during my lifetime except for this right
now this intermediate period that much
feature has been closed through due to
some major flooding but all facts
indicate that this will be going through
a quick recovery so my point here is
that this production of ruta
cosmopolitanism is not going to stop
some of the global corporate investments
it's not going to stop the production of
secluded and homogeneous places that get
created by various actors or erase the
instant consumption and disposal that
comes with tourism but my proposal is by
acknowledging the production of rooted
cosmopolitanism we create development
choices development choices that address
the social and spatial justice and
recognize the histories and cultures and
identities of the city of Cuzco thank
you very much another very excellent
presentation and reminded me of that
first visit in the 60s 1960s I should
have to Cuzco maybe before some of the
work i started in i met one of the young
children dressed in traditional costumes
and i asked to take a picture and she
gladly agree to do to do so and i
thought this was an example of my charm
at work and my Spanish was really better
than I thought and as soon as the
picture was taken and a charming smile
produced the hand went out so i think
what comes out to me as an economist
looking at much of what medium is
presented to us is how entrepreneurial
these people are and it given a chance
to participate media in their own
development they can they can really
develop this concept of rooted
cosmopolitanism to which I'm grateful to
you for that concept James I haven't met
james at bunco asking maybe take your
place James Freeman is next and from
what I have of your background professor
freeman is a lecturer still at concordia
I in University in Montreal has his
degree also from University of
California Berkeley so there's something
of a something to Amanda something I
think they're that is that James did it
in geography and and most importantly
for us he spent a very pierced of I'm
very productive you're doing research in
rio de janeiro at the oh fer a java
there in which no doubt contributed the
production of his paper on this
wonderfully iconic a neighborhood of
ipanema global and local in post
countercultural neighborhoods i don't
think i'm sorry the formal title is if
my name in the 1960s gobo bohemia in a
latin america metropolis oh this is
again a paper to look forward to welcome
James
okay yeah so actually I changed the
title so it wasn't your fault the old
title is actually a bit more snappy but
this one's more descriptive what I'm
talking about here so Ipanema is a is a
elite beach neighborhood in Rio de
Janeiro and I'm talking about ipanema as
a post 1960s counterculture neighborhood
and let me see a little bit about how I
arrived at this I grew up in San
Francisco I studied at Berkeley for many
years I lived in Kreuzberg in Berlin and
then one day I arrived in Ipanema to do
field work and I I looked around I said
there's something familiar here there's
a common thread and I started to think
that maybe there's something like a post
1960s counterculture neighborhood that
there's some sort of something left over
some sort of culture that gets
perpetuated over time and so I set out
to study this and what what I want to
argue is that that the night there was a
moment in the 1960s particularly 1968
where there was sort of a global
convergence where there was a global
youth counterculture movement and there
was a series of urban revolts and
neighborhoods around in cities around
the world you know Paris of course and
prague and mexico city often accompanied
by severe oppression and so i want to
kind of explain this this global moment
and what I'm arguing is that that this
was a collective product that this was
produced in a series of urban
neighborhoods around the world and that
it had significant urban consequences so
and so what I want to do here is make an
argument about how how global culture
works and how culture travels and we all
know this story but this is that this is
a concrete case where I've I've thought
about this a bit and I want to argue
that you know global he me of 1968 was
really a collective product that was a
lot of places were contributing and
consuming
producing but there is a certain
inequality between north and south for
example that that we can talk about
unequal cultural exchange maybe a
certain kind of cultural dependency but
that at least in in Rio and Ipanema in
Brazil who are on the receiving end of
this global culture in a lot of ways
that people very consciously borrowed
and assimilated ideas and picked and
picked and shoes and integrated them
into long-standing local traditions and
deploy them in a completely different
context in a very different rebellion
and so where where does this 1968 moment
come from it's a long story and I'll try
to make it brief but there's a global
economic moment the post-world war two
economic boom was pretty Universal
around the world and had different
consequences of different places but
it's certainly in Europe and North
America it meant a vast growth of
middle-class living standards and
particularly a large growth in student
population the other part of it is a
global sort of political moment where
you know after world war two there's an
interest in in democracy and
self-determination and there's there's a
rise of third-world nationalisms and
then of course we have Vietnam it's this
inspires rebellion around the world and
then there's a technological story where
this is a moment of a capitalist
expansion of course capitalism continues
to expand and technological innovation
and there's innovation particularly in
transportation and communication
technology so it becomes the world
becomes a much more global much more
tightly knit place and people are moving
around much more freely and culture and
ideas are moving around much more freely
and of course because the global
entertainment industries are developing
in an unprecedented way and
for Latin America there's a regional
contest and the most important thing for
Latin America really is the Cuban
Revolution where the Cuban Revolution
this is a bit of an anachronistic usage
but it shows that that another world is
possible right and so it was very
inspiring for for young people in latin
america latin america had industrialized
dramatically it had urbanize
dramatically in this period but in a
very unequal way and the Cuban
Revolution offered possibilities and
hope for a lot of people who wanted to
change things particularly young people
intellectuals people on the left and it
represented a serious threat for the
United States for for the right in Latin
America and so you have this moment
where there's there's political
possibilities and there's severe
oppression going at the same time this
is a general Latin American condition
and then a Latin America you have a big
growth in students as well and so just
to tell you about Brazil in 1960 there
were 36 thousand places and universities
for students by 1968 there were 90
thousand places for students but there
was also a dramatic growth in and the
access student population so that meant
that there are a whole lot of people who
are qualified to get into the university
but didn't have the Reno place for the
university so in 1966 there were sixty
five thousand left excess students in
Brazil and by 1968 the peak of the
student rebellion in Brazil there were
125,000 excess students and so I mean
students are not the whole story but but
they're an important part of the story
there are people have a certain amount
of leisure and their creative and
they're thinking they're coming together
and in Rio they're concentrating they
are they are the producers and the
consumers of the counterculture they are
the artists they are the intellectuals
they're the poets and Ipanema was the
center of this of this of this
counterculture
in rio and i should say the important
context in brazil also is that in 1964
there was a military coup and then from
nineteen sixty nine to nineteen seventy
three was the hardline the military
dictatorship so a serious crack down on
any sort of opposition but this was the
period of Brazilian counterculture none
above and the Golden Age of ipanema so
we're talking basically 1962 1973 is the
golden age of ipanema when ipanema it
becomes one of these counterculture
neighborhoods and the story is that
prior to this the 1920s through the
1950s Copacabana is the cosmopolitan
neighborhood is the place to be in
Brazil it is it is worldly it is
cosmopolitan in the sense of high status
and worldliness movie stars from all
around the world are landing in
Copacabana but Copacabana kind of
spilled over into Ipanema and this this
kind of allows me to start with to talk
about culture kind of with a capital C
and talk about some cultural production
and one of the important movements that
founded Ipanema was the bossa nova
movement so both snow is a style of
music I'm sure you're all familiar with
and the bus lenovo sonova dates from the
late 1950s and really until the early
60s and the both of them musicians were
playing in heap in Copacabana and
entertaining in co in copacabana
nightlife and many of them started
around nineteen sixty started moving to
ipanema to define cheap housing because
it was on the edge of of copacabana and
so this is this is really the
colonization of this neighborhood by a
bohemian class they're hanging out in
bars and Ipanema they're hanging out on
the beach in Ipanema and they develop a
certain style of beach use and bar use
and public socializing that becomes very
important for the development of ipanema
a second movement is listen a manova
movement
cinema movement which is a which was
sort of an avant-garde movement of the
same period drawing its inspiration from
italian and french avant-garde cinema
now both of these movements have been
charged with being derived particularly
bossa nova has been accused of being
Americanized grafting American jazz on
to Brazilian Samba and I want to make an
argue about arguing about culture that
is a bit more complicated than that Bosa
Nova was it was clearly a movement to
modernize Brazilian movement to escape
the past in a lot of ways but it very
conscious it was inspired by certainly
by American pop music and by jazz but it
very consciously and very carefully
reworked Brazilian rhythms and created
something absolutely new and so there's
ways that it's you know it's part of
international culture mean the way these
people are dressed looks very 1960 right
and the same thing with cinema Nova it's
you know it's drawing inspiration from
from French and Italian and film but
it's focusing on Brazilian themes
poverty under development right
and then I want to talk about a third
kind of cultural production and this is
a something that maybe doesn't register
outside of Brazil very much but a group
of people call the festive left and this
was a group of people of the same
generation as the bossa nova and the
cinema Nova Nova crowds and they founded
two very important institutions so this
is a group of mostly journalists some
connections to other other sort of
artists intellectuals and their
associated with a particular bar Jon
Gabrus and a particular spot on the
beach montenegro and they had they were
starting to assimilate some of these
international cultural trends of
hedonism and sort of kind of lifestyles
that were going against the dominant
norms and so they were hard drinking no
partners Bohemians and they created two
very important institutions that that I
think you know they're they're very
local and very global in different ways
the first one is the bondage Ipanema and
budget Ipanema is a carnival group and
it was founded in nineteen sixty-five in
the wake of the of the military coup of
1964 and so this is a group of guys
initially who would they would dress
like this with you know boater hats and
jackets and parade through the
neighborhood pretending to play
instruments we didn't know how and they
would parade past the bars and try to
get their friends to join they would
parade down the beach particular trying
to get women in bikinis to join and pray
down the the streets with them and then
we do silly things like trying to ride a
donkey into a bar you know this person
very urban place and so they developed a
style of zany humor that really became
identified with with Ipanema and the
second movement is from the same group
is called pass skiing and pesky the the
global routes are a bit easier to trace
it is it was an underground newspaper
and it was inspired by underground
newspapers in places like Berkeley and
all around the world
and it was really developed in the wake
of the coup within the coop and the way
in the wake of the hardening of the
military dictatorship in December 1968
and it it's humor it's cartoons it
develops it writes in slang and you can
you could really see the influences of
things like you know freak brothers
underground comics and and Mad Magazine
and things like this but it develops its
own language and it's it ends up you
know being this being the largest
circulation national newspaper at some
point in the in the in the 1970s and it
particularly thrived during the hardline
of the military dictatorship during the
when it was under censorship so this is
what this this image represents because
these artists derive great pleasure of
submitting a subversive message despite
the sensors in very subtle ways but so I
want to engage this argument that that
Brazil is a receiver of culture and that
it's it sort of has a relationship of
cultural dependence and I wanna start
with a couple of anecdotes the first one
is that in january nineteen sixty eight
mick jagger and marion and faith
marianne faithfull visited rio and they
were hosted by members of the festive
left by some of these journalists who
took them around and what is interesting
is the clash of cultures between these
two groups so the these journalists are
wearing you know coats and ties and
they're meeting the meeting Mick Jagger
who is got long hair he's going to
floppy hat he's got one of these you
know these leather shirts with them with
the fringes on it and you know Marianne
Faithfull and Mick Jagger are talking
about LSD trips and they've got this
sort of a new age philosophy going on
and so this is the comment that one of
these journalists made about this moment
he said how could we reconcile our
Christian upbringing with that torrent
of shocking information about a
counterculture that hadn't land
here yet so hadn't landed here yeah it
has to arrive a couple years later right
and then huh skiing how to column called
underground the words are in English
which reported on counter culture
movements in other parts of the world
and this con was initiated in 1970 and
this is a comment from the journalist
who wrote regularly wrote this column I
had first-hand information because of
pass keen reader named Jacques hood who
had gone to study in berkeley had gone
to study in berkeley he sent me what
came out in the Alternative Press he was
in California at the birthplace of the
whole counter culture thing near San
Francisco where the beat were the beat
poets were he sent me the publication
publications and I put them in the
column Brazilian counterculture was
influenced and copied to a large degree
from abroad I don't believe there would
have been a counterculture movement in
Brazil if it hadn't been invented by the
Americans and so I'm going to disagree
with him and I want to argue that you
know yes certain forms were borrowed but
it was absolutely different and so I
want to talk about counterculture proper
in Brazil which really starts to look
like hippie culture around 1971 I was
particularly associated with a spot on
the beach called the pier and the story
of the pier is that ipanema was booming
it was going from low rise to high rise
during this period and the city
government decided to build a sewage
pipe that would take all the sewage from
the neighborhood and send it through
four kilometres out into the into the
open ocean and so in order to do this
they had to dredge and they had to make
this pier and so the dredging meant that
they were huge piles of sand piled up on
the beach which normally doesn't have
prominent sand dunes and so people would
go to the sand dunes to hi bana sanam to
smoke marijuana right and this is for
the beginning of the pier in the pier
becomes the hippie counterculture place
this is also the moment of tropicalia
and so tropicalia is another Brazilian
musical movement that's
you might be familiar with particularly
associated with caetano veloso Schubert
Lucille and in this case gal cost is an
important figure because she hung out at
the pier regularly for at least a year
and so caitanya and Jill would return
from exile because many Brazilian
intellectual artists leftists were in
exile during this hard line phase with
the military dictatorship and they hung
out here at the pier and so the pier in
some ways looks very much like hippie
counterculture anywhere but but it's
being but as being grafted onto this
this long-standing Beach tradition which
you know into my work I've traced back
to the 19th century even and and it's
being deployed as a rebellion against
this hardline phase of the military
dictatorship which does not allow any
real open rebellion so it's a very
interesting context let me read a couple
of quotes of descriptions of the pier
during this period young people with
different heads who wanted to change the
world with different weapons than those
used by the guerrilla movement a crowd
that loved the Beatles stones Hendrix
cream caetano Jill and the hoop then a
second commentary the pier became the
hippy beach of ipanema great open-air
underground the fashion at the pier was
long skirts with belly buttons showing
and Indian tunics there were people who
went around dressed in San Tropez pants
overalls and even Poncho's under a son
of 40 degrees rarely did the did the
enter the water when did not shave the
armpits many girls were proud of their
triumphal Tufts people greeted each
other with kisses on the mouth it wasn't
a beach it was an attitude and another I
have several of these quotes another
quote the dictatorship continued to be
very rough but on that piece of seashore
people cultivated a democratic culture
one breathe or tried to breathe freely
then you found there you found beautiful
free light and loose people there was a
for it was there it was forbidden to
forbid this is of course a slogan from
may 68 demonstrations in Paris the
people wanted to open wide the doors and
windows of perception and this is a
reference to all the Saxbys book called
the doors of perception and then my
final quote about the pier the
dictatorship of general Medici was at
its peak people were dead and tortured
in the dungeons of repression and the
former students demonstrators and
subversives who had unsuccessfully tried
to change the regime went to warm
themselves in the Sun like lazy lizards
the days were long and beautiful and
Ipanema was always a party so how is
this possible see all of these people
who were part of these cultural
movements were we're mobile they were
spending time you know many of them were
in exile in Paris in Rome in London
during much of this period some of them
were studying at Berkeley pass skiing
had foreign correspondents right they
had a foreign correspondent in Greenwich
Village they had a guy who had said
regular right with regular columns from
Greenwich Village chico buarque another
famous musician was the foreign
correspondent from from rome he wrote
regular columns and passing from Rome so
this is this is this is not some
isolated place this is a place that is
integrated with the world as people are
moving around receiving stuff from
everywhere and they're deploying it in
their own particular struggle against
the the Brazilian dictatorship and the
social norms of Brazil at that time and
so let me say something about the post
counterculture neighborhood for one
thing it and I think this is like a lot
of post countercultural neighborhoods it
ipanema is a cosmopolitan a
transnational place for brazilians
especially people in rio who don't live
in the south zone EP name is the place
to go to see the world you go to ipanema
to see what the latest fashions are you
go to ipanema with the idea that maybe
you're going to be on television you go
to even able to rub shoulders with with
you know celebrities Madonna was there
last week and Alicia Keys and whoever
else
and of course local celebrities you know
soccer stars but it's a place to see the
world and yet from the perspective of
the world what could be more Brazilian
than Ipanema I mean this is the this is
the view of the Brazil that we get is
Ipanema it's it's the cliché image and
so Ipanema is a place that people have
to come to when they come to Brazil so
it's this in-between sort of thing
another thing that a podium has common
with a lot of post counterculture
neighborhoods is the myth there has been
there is a very strong myth of this
period it's as you go through this
neighborhood the past is always on the
president's always sort of hanging over
your shoulder and there are people who
have made it their business to be myth
makers and to understand is just think
about the cultural production of his
period this was this was a period that
produced music art theatre film poskan
was that was a laboratory for journalism
so these were these were young
cartoonists and journalists who went on
to become the dominant journalists of
Brazil or certainly of Rio in later
periods and so all of these people
produced work that that celebrated the
period and so my second point is that
there's been a certain reproduction of
Bohemia here that people are attracted
by the myth and they seek to relive this
moment and there's also a certain way
that culture is passed down a bit more
organically as people use the spaces and
interact with other people they learn
ways of behaving and attitudes and ways
of speaking another common thread in
post bohemian neighborhoods is
gentrification and commodification and
Ipanema is thoroughly gentrified it is
probably the most expensive place to
live in Rio and and probably the most
desirable place to live in Rio so
Bohemia has attracted bushwa Bohemians
in Ipanema and there are many ways that
that that the the history has been
commodified here's one of them this is
the bar where
Tom jobean and Vinnie systematize
apparently saw some beautiful girl
walking towards the beach and wrote the
famous Girl From Ipanema song and so now
it's it's the girl from ipanema bar but
there are there are you know lines of
clothing that that capitalize on the
Ipanema image multiple you know music
and biographies and retrospectives and
then this is a happening place and so
anyone who wants to market something
goes to ipanema to market it and then
okay so this is my there is a sort of a
bohemian culture here that in the
smallest see sense where that people are
people are liberal in ipanema people
vote to the left people have liberal
attitudes people are very laid back
casual to have very have a very casual
sort of slang that they used to speak
they're interested in health food and
the environment and nature and so all
sort of things we would associate kind
of left the post hippie places and then
they're the most important thing for me
is that there's a tradition of use of
public space in ipanema that has been
that has been passed down and
particularly it's pretty clear to me in
the way that people use the beach and
the bar as a space of conversation but
also as a space of creativity so you
know already in the 1960s you have these
cultural producers hanging out in bars
hanging out the beach using public space
in a certain way and they're exchanging
ideas and their networking and their
brainstorming and they are putting
together people to do projects on the
beach in the bars this is something that
this is a tradition that is absolutely
alive today and so interviewing someone
on the beach last year when i had the
portion of being there she was telling
me that she's in the in the film
industry and to put together a film you
know you're on the beach and you you
find your actors and you find your
camera men and you find your found
people they're all there there there
it's a dense network of creative people
who operate on the speeches i think this
is one of the things that gets passed
down and i think a lot of bohemian
neighborhoods around the world have sort
of a creative culture tradition that
gets passed down
and then finally I want you something
about carnival ok this is the bondage
Ipanema today and I has been exploited
but those are my children on the right
having a close encounter with the
bondage Ipanema the bond jeepin ava is a
oldest bohemian Ipanema traditionally it
has become a bit of a gay parade and so
the global angle here is simply that I
feel very much like I'm in a gay pride
parade in San Francisco when I when I go
to when I see the bondage Ipanema and of
course ipanema is is it is a gay
destination and as are many many post
leukemia neighborhoods have become gay
neighborhoods or spin-off gay neighbor
hoods and that is the case of people
named it and then the latest thing is
the booming of Street carnival so the
bungee Pineda was was the four-run
forerunner in 1965 in 1985 at the end of
the military dictatorship there is a new
round of invention of Street carnival in
Ipanema okay I'm stop stop and it
started out very small and this this
year in carnival were 3.5 million people
participating in Street carnival up from
two million last year up from a million
year before up from a couple of thousand
when i was there 10 years ago and this
is something that's created in the beach
and anyway so i always got there thanks
Jim that was great at the whole
afternoon is taking on an
autobiographical stands for me I I was i
lived in rio and about the early 70s and
i want to thank you to explain to me
what was going on around me i I look for
myself and one of those beach folders
there I would have been the you the
palest or the reddest a person on the on
the beach at that time but it was very
informative and i look forward to
discussions with you Gina about the very
serious issues I think that lie behind
that very colorful and interesting
presentation Marissa Zapata is our final
speaker maurices promised me she hasn't
changed the title of her to talk which
is if she has she will revert back to
what I'm saying it's going to be it's a
multi cult multicultural participatory
planning Norman of ideals and pragmatic
realities in monteverde Costa Rica so
it's a wonderfully innovative case study
that Maurice is going to present to us
and i'll start by saying maressa didn't
go to the University of California
Berkeley she so she brings welcome
diversity at a certain respect to that
she has her pc iguess recently right
Marisa congratulations from University
of Illinois in regional planning and now
as an assistant professor of ritual
planning I suspect at the University of
Cincinnati so it's nice to have you
thanks for coming and welcome Marissa so
I guess I didn't change my presentation
title it was the presentation title in
the program is different from the
presentation title here but matches with
what the discussant just read so I think
we're all on board first I want to thank
lata for inviting me to participate in
this it's been really exciting to get
back to my work in Costa Rica I haven't
been as engaged as I finished up my
dissertation as I would have liked to
have been I come to the table with an
idea about asking questions about how we
incorporate public participation in
planning processes I fundamentally want
to ask how do we do that in
are transnational and multi cultural
spaces how do we create plans that
reflect shared values if we can't even
identify what those shared values are
and I was particularly interested in the
opportunity to work in in Costa Rica to
explore how to cultural groups that were
living and working together conceived a
participation and the development of the
community's first legally empowered
public planning process I was looking at
differences between social groups that
were shaping participatory activities
and what is called the district of month
or earth day and month of a theater
region was located on the Pacific slope
at the very top of the Pacific slope in
Costa Rica it's a very small region of
about 5,000 people so again going back
to these ideas of rural areas and what's
happening in them Costa Rica was settled
in the mid 1900s by costa rican farmers
campesinos and expatriated the United
States Quakers from Alabama so in the
early 1940s late 1950s we were trying to
see the emergence of a very
multicultural transnational community
over the years the region would be
discovered for its eco diversity and
with that would come biologists and
scientists from around the world to talk
about the environmental sustainability
of the region and with that has come
hippie movements from Argentina
primarily and as well as Western
Europeans who bought property and
settled into the area so the community
is very transnational one thing has been
very exciting today is that usually when
I present a month ago today I feel like
I'm talking about this very unique
bizarre place and in the context of all
the towns we've heard about today
Monteverde seems pretty normal which is
an exciting and refreshing perspective
what I really thought was interesting in
the context of Monteverde was again this
idea these Quakers settling with poster
rican campesinos and living together and
how they governed together and then
specifically this idea of Quakers and
what they bring to the table about
consensus and this had become an
increasingly problematic term for me in
the participation participatory
literature and planning what does it
mean to come to consensus what are we
asking people when we ask them to reach
agreement about something and so Quakers
I'll talk about later have a very
particular idea of what that looks like
and it was very exciting for me to be
able to see Quakers living in a
community
trying to reach agreement and bring
people together on particular activities
and then finally was this emergence of a
legal empowerment for the region to
actually be able to conduct a planning
process and produce with called a
plumber I thought or when the United
States what we would commonly refer to
as a comprehensive plan or a land-use
plant this was a major achievement for
the community in and of itself this is
just a basic location map it shows you
where Monteverde is in relationship to
the rest of Costa Rica this is the early
settlements 1940s 1950s you can see this
mud road it hasn't changed very much
during the wet season they use ox carts
to get up the mountain it is just as
hard sometimes to get down the mountain
and this plays into why the community
felt that they really needed to try to
seek their own legal powers to be able
to plan of course we had the infamous
biological indigo diversity community
that comes from Monteverde most notably
what put most month already on the map
was a discovery of that kilo died right
down there the golden toad he was
discovered and from there everyone just
became very excited about the
interesting and different indigenous
species but with that came an interest
of the entire world to see those species
month orale is known for having a
network of private reserves to protect
the land and it's not public so they're
not run by the government it's a network
of three private reserves one of the
most famous is the children's eternal
rainforest and children from Sweden
banded together to send money over to
Monteverde to be able to buy land and
put it together and be able to save it
and protect it from development in doing
so it also created an interest in these
swedish children to come in the 1990s
and see this beautiful rainforest that
they had actually protected so this
network of reserved this biodiversity
and the tourism that eventually grow
with it has become what Costa Rica has
no is largely known for that is an
eco-tourist movement and he go to agenda
as that ecotourism has grown the region
has grown as well population has grown
and you can see here these are the kind
of five main towns or little urban areas
of the region luciano santa elena
Monteverde visit uncle Monteverde said
oakland and san luis santa elena is the
largest most dense areas where most of
the Costa Ricans lab so we also see some
spatial steps Saturday shin patterns the
town of month Aranda is where the
quakers originally settled and were most
additional gringos those Gringo's who
come as scientists will settle in so the
plan will be in the middle of the two
functions is our nice typical urban
transition area where we see some mixing
of people from different backgrounds and
land-use patterns miley son Luis is a
rural area that is mostly costa rican
and moshe ah knows is another rural area
that is actually primarily occupied by
foreigners who own property and come in
only for a short period of time so
you're going to get a sense of all the
different populations we have living in
this region and obviously the
complexities of trying to plan this
region brings up a lot of questions as
to who has rights to the city who has
rights to this space to make plans for
it and to support it for the future
shows you the settlement pattern of
something lena it also shows you with
kind of what the limited resources in
which the region is working with and
ordered a plan it's a very basic GIS map
it's not the kind of graphics that we
saw from presenters earlier and this is
student done drawn on the fly wearing a
little headset to find their GPS
locations and that's the reality of them
trying to practice fishes you on the
left the deforestation that has happened
in the region on the right that is one
of the reserves so it's showing it just
demonstrates that yes if the reserves
are in place we do protect them the
reserves are not in place than we do
lose massive amounts of forest coverage
to farming activities and month or edit
primarily the farming activity is dairy
farming that was brought by the quakers
that's what they did in Alabama and it's
what they started doing in Costa Rica as
well there's also a lot of coffee
farming as well so in addition to the
threats of deforestation with this
growth and the men around the mid 90s as
a tourist economy started to boom
Nicaraguan started coming into
to try to find jobs other Costa Ricans
started moving into the region to try to
find jobs and take advantage of these
tourist opportunities with this
unprecedented growth rates that the
region cannot manage the region itself
has no local power or authority it rests
on its municipality County and province
all that goes by the name of Puntarenas
but the Rhenus is geographically located
on the ocean and so it takes two and a
half to three hours to get them put the
rain it's up this mud entrenched road to
coast routes a month of air that and
month of air they found that they really
couldn't rely on puntarenas to provide
them any support fiscally or logistical
t to be able to govern their region and
to try to actually make plans and
enforce development codes and standards
and so some of these things we think of
as being very maybe not being that
threatening but for the month of our
region can be particularly threatening
so we see here some kind of haphazard
development patterns we see here the
very friendly canopy walk along with the
ability to wear and sly forget what
those things are called when you slide
down from the trees anybody remember zip
line thank you you've never actually
done one despite spending a lot of time
and a region that has lots of them but
it's really unclear what kind of impact
these kind of tourist activities have on
the ecosystem and on the region itself
one of the more controversial activities
i think has actually finally been
stopped was a paint paintball gun war
zone so you could pay money to go and
try to chase each other in the Rick
cloud forest and shoot each other with
paintballs guns as a particularly
important given this is a Quaker
community and Quakers are pacifists so
they were not excited to see not only
the force being used as being used with
an activity that might be exploiting it
but also being used to bring up these
images of violence and war the region
has serious issues with grey water
runoff so you see these lovely children
playing in grey water and then finally
you see new development and building
these are just an example of a structure
that's gone in and then increased truck
traffic and vehicular traffic it's again
unclear how much impact having all of
these tourist buses coming
has on the region the largest reserve
has finally put into place mechanisms to
limit the number of people who go in so
if you go to want the vert that you
might not actually go to the largest and
most famous reserve because they are
only going to let X number people
through the region through that forest
in any one period of time to give you a
sense of the dynamic of how largest
tourist population is the tourist
industry estimates anywhere from 150
thousand two hundred and fifty thousand
people visit this region every year
5,000 people call this place home so
we're seeing some really mass magnitudes
of scale in terms of how the community
is going to try to manage the growth in
the tourist industry while also being
able to take care of themselves this is
a project that I worked on with an
institute in Monteverde and it was an
idea of different ways of scenarios to
project different ways that we could
arrange density patterns to help address
the growth issue and help manage growth
issues and this was part of what kind of
exemplified month of air they up until
about the mid-90s and this was their
ability to self-govern so because the
quakers has such an influence in the
area the quakers come from a very long
tradition of self-government the first
and foremost is that they have a very
important town hall meeting people come
to the town hall meeting they have very
serious debates over issues secondly
within that structure they have a very
binding consensus building process if
you think weak consensus exists it
doesn't exist in the Quaker community
Quakers come together they believe that
through deliberation and discussion you
can reach very important decisions
together and collectively the longest
discussion and deliberation I heard
about in Monteverde and the Quaker town
hall meeting was four days and that was
to decide whether to build a bridge and
they debated it and deliberated it
they're very much guided by the notion
of spirituality and God and the belief
that through prayer and through being
together in their town hall and in their
place of worship but they will be guided
for the right decision they are so
committed to this that one person can
actually stop a consensus building
process so that if one person feels that
this is a moral issue that this project
or decision cannot be made they can
actually choose to
the entire project you can also choose
to do is called stand aside which is to
simply say I don't feel like an support
this project but I don't feel strongly
enough to stop it which is a little like
abstaining but with a little bit more
depth to it up until in mid 90s the
Quakers also really believe in
committees it's kind of a joke in the
community we're just going to form a
committee to address that problem and
solve that issue and yes you see
committees everywhere and the Costa
Ricans in the region have also picked
this up so every Institute every
activity every idea has a committee that
goes with it and it's actually a place
where you see a lot of interaction
between Costa Ricans Quakers Gringo's
environmentalists who are in the area so
the committee's for the committee serve
a purpose that goes much more beyond
just how they are making decisions on a
particular issue they're actually
servicing the social interactions the
community need has needed to make a lot
of decisions and creating relationships
and sustaining them and consistent
saying these informal networks I weigh
on a trip to a land to visit a landowner
with someone and got to see one of these
informal networks at play someone at
that invited someone else over as
someone tagged along we all went over
and then I got to watch the most the
best part of informal networking which
is social pressure direct social
pressure not to make a particular
decision and this is how the community
has been largely focused on operating in
the mid 90s the community realized they
were growing too fast the town hall
meeting structure wouldn't be working
when continue to work there had been a
lot of tensions between the Quaker and
the Costa Rican community are the
campesinos who had been originally there
they had this new influx of populations
that had come in they were really trying
to grapple with how are we going to
vision for our future and how are we
going to actually create policies for
our future they created a process Club
month of air they bein da bank they they
came together they really emphasize the
importance of stakeholder collaboration
from a wide range of viewpoints they
deliberately put people at the table
that didn't get along with each other to
try to come up with an articulated
vision instead of plans and
recommendations for the future
unfortunately one of the biggest
learning outcomes for them through that
process was that they had no legal
authority so what was the point and
that's could be a whole other
conversation because a lot of good
things to come
that process but a lot of people were
very frustrated had a very hard time
realizing that the impact didn't have
the legal power to enact any of these
ideas they had to depend on one another
to actually follow any policies that
came up with so this really left the
community thinking okay what we really
need is ability to self-govern so this
is a picture of the province of
puntarenas this is done by the velocity
on the national newspaper I think it's
great because number one is Puntarenas
you can see this on the ocean and
Monteverde is up here they forgot to
include it in the boundary so which kind
of emphasizes that yes mon frere they is
forgotten both literally and physically
in visualizations of the region but yes
the the area in which they were having
to seek all their government and support
was from down here they recognize this
wasn't working and they fought very hard
to be recognized as what is called a
district or a municipal district it
required a change and reform to the
Constitution so they fought very hard
for their right to actually govern
themselves they founded a district this
is the boundaries of the district you
can see on the far right the the massive
reserve that i showed the aerial photo
of earlier in founding this district the
one of the most important and exciting
things for the community leaders who
evolved in this process was to create
this plan dragon either or this land use
plan now before I went down as they were
discovering this process as things were
unfolding for them and before they had
actually achieved this status everyone
in the community community members
community leaders were very excited
about this plan my lord and would say
yes we're going to be able to vision
we're going able to talk about what our
future is going to look like where I'm
going to talk about education we're
going to talk about land use protecting
the environment health social inequality
you know listing off all the things that
you expect a community to hear when they
hear we're going to do a comp plan and
unfortunately one of the first things
that the plan commission had to learn is
that a plan regulatory is a basic land
use plan
and that's exemplified by the last few
points there defines the plan Margaret
now the Nash nation of Costa Rica
actually sets forth all legislation
related to plan my girl gone and
dictates what it should be done and how
it should be done these are the areas in
which the plan regular one has Authority
and the localities are expected to plan
again you can see this is just basic
land use planning we're looking at basic
how how are you going to develop where
the political systems and infrastructure
do a basic cursory study of the
population land-use circulation studies
community services public services
housing and where needed objectives
about housing so we're not really
getting into these large visioning
efforts or the larger participatory
interest in which the community really
had driven them to deal with this to
want to be able to do this plan ragazzo
now don't get me wrong they were very
concerned about growth management and
how to address land use planning so they
were concerned about this but it meant
that in some instances they were very
much problematized by how they were
going to actually engage the public make
people excited about this process while
recognizing that they couldn't really do
a lot about all of these other issues
and we see that as much in the United
States and planning practice as we do
other places this kind of question of
what are we getting the public excited
about what do we actually have legal
authority to do what can we actually
create and do this going to have teeth
the second problem that the Planning
Commission faced right on who is that
after all of us at Fir to become a
district and to create a plan and to
have legal authority they got hit with
no in fact districts do not have the
legal authority to fully make their
plant you have to actually rely on the
municipality so as they they already
started the planning process I'd already
hired a consultant that our date on all
this work and suddenly they're being
told no now you have to go back up in
dead earnest and you have to deal with
everything I boom today and that's
including the party politics that every
Costa Rican wanted to stay out of
because that is going to be who actually
says that your plan
is okay so this was a major setback for
them and really halted their planning
effort and put it and put it to a
standstill this was what they were at
the point they were at when they stopped
on the right you can see probably the
most important thing the zoning map and
the map of the land use policies was not
enacted before their their power to
actually plan and hire their own
consultant was pulled and meant that
they had to actually deal with what to
do next and how to go forward and the
last time I there was there people were
just pretty moralized and feeling very
down about their ability to plan locally
so what so what's the point of all of us
I was really interested in how people
thought about public participation how
participation was enacted across these
different cultural groups and I really
concede a participation in two ways I
looked first at the Planning Commission
panning Commission is appointed to
volunteer group and oddly enough it was
split fifty percent Costa Rican and
fifty percent Tico and this is a variant
was very unusual when compared to the
other commissions in the municipality
where there were no green goes Gringo's
were not involved anywhere except for on
this commission it was also interesting
to see how they played out there rules
differently the Costa Ricans have taken
on the role of party politics most of
the gringos did not have legal voting
rights in Costa Rica and really had no
interest in being involved in Party
politics the Costa Ricans didn't really
want to be involved in Party politics
but recognized that's what their
opportunity was that's where their
strength was that they could actually
engage and be able to make a difference
the work on the Planning Commission
really i think reveals the nuanced
conceptions of identity especially
national identity that goes on in Costa
Rica as issues and are being determined
although now the quaker and gringo
population is very small and proportion
to the Costa Rican population the
history of having a Quaker community
having a white community living in
Monteverde is still very prominent and a
lot of the discourse there were two
discussions that really I think
Illustrated that the leader of a new
Institute a new leader came into an
stitute and wanted to join the join the
plan commission and the Planning
Commission said no we're not going to
have another gringo on this commission
we're done and thank you and then
someone said well she's not really
gringo she's a philippine-american and
the person that the Costa Ricans all
said okay that's fine she's not really
American then and then he rejected the
offer of a student volunteer because she
was a white green go in the same meeting
they rejected because the student was
white it's also play out in my identity
I was off I've often well the Institute
that I worked through nicknamed me la
mexicana as we met my Mexicans friends
like to point out I'm as Mexican as a
frozen burrito but in the context of
month or na this idea of a new ones
identity of what it meant to be American
was very much tied into a white
anglo-saxon American you could be
anything else and be accepted into
activities but if you were white
anglo-saxon American they were going to
be much more skeptical with where
they're going to involve you or not and
then finally this idea that as tensions
move as the Commission move forward
although a lot of these tensions kind of
surfaced on bubble they weren't so
pressing that the Commission felt that
they had to take a break and address
them to commissioners did express the
concern that as they move forward from
these more abstracted idea that they
would have more significant problems I'm
going to go through these other things
really fast mostly in terms of public
participation there was a lot of
agreement everyone was very committed to
social justice they wanted to hear
marginalized voices now where they
disagreed especially long lines of
national identity was one of that
hearing meant actually doing something
was it enough to hear voices or did you
actually have to change the plan many
people felt that they would like to
change the plan but recognize that they
didn't have that opportunity or that
luxury and they really felt that there
was a difference between educating the
public over what they should be doing vs
the co-creation of a plan and Costa
Ricans and campus
Quakers and campesinos really wanted to
try to do this co-creation of a plan
gringos who had moved in in the last 10
years and most Costa Ricans who had
moved in the last 10 years well I just
educate people and move forward by the
time I gotten back to Costa Rica most
people have recognized that without
public by and there would be no
implementation of the plan and so that
had become their most pressing concern
with the aspects of public participation
they wanted people to be able to
implement the plan and support the plan
I think this project really illustrates
the idea that we have a very complex
idea of power and I want to thank
faranak for giving me feedback actually
many years ago on this paper on this
particular issue I've kind of shied away
from it I welcome input on how to deal
with this I this notion of power is very
complex amounted are they people say
okay well the gringos can just leave
they have that ultimate pass they might
say they're invested in the community
but they can just pack up and go so
that's a very powerful car at the same
time you look at the community and it's
like well who cares if they go they
don't have that much money they're not
running a lot of the businesses there's
not that many of them left is that
really a powerful card at this stage and
then I mean you see the way that people
were recognizing what they had agency
over so Costa Ricans recognizing that
they had agency over this ability to
actually influence political politics
party politics engage in their national
political system well Ringo's held a
technical power they were seeing as
being the experts on this land use
planning process land use planning was
from North America so we're going to
have the gringos help us do the land use
planning process it didn't matter that
none of them had ever done a land use
planning process and then I mean as I
said their ability to actually move away
so in summary I had really thought about
this idea this kind of subtle ways a
power and how does how is it influencing
what's going on this idea of
participation really wanting to ask
questions about how we could do planning
differently and transnational
communities that do our planning process
actually support us understanding our
opportunities our differences in our
synergies when it comes to thinking
about participation and how we can
actually engage it and enact it and then
perhaps actually looking at different
spaces to can
sitter this so instead of thinking of
thinking that participation looks the
same across the board maybe in the plan
commission we work to do what would John
dry zach has dubbed medic consensus or
what the Quakers would consider this
deep consensus building maybe our plan
commissions are the places where we want
people to go off and commune together
and reach very deep enter subjective
understanding on abstracted values and
issues but when we actually have public
input sessions maybe that really is more
about public education and it checks and
balances so and some that's really
that's really it I'm just wanting to ask
questions about how we continue to think
about participation in these contexts
thank you are we doing for time do we
need to cut short a little bit our local
mean but what time shall we go to
okay I've intended it gets fine okay
it's a pleasure to be here I hope you
enjoyed as much as i did that these
presentations Thank You Marissa it's
just as well either I've got an hour's
of the comments or five minutes claro
you're right so I think I'll see if I
can work on the five minute version just
to remind us maybe what we've heard and
and leave 10 minutes for people to to
comment I'll start with maurices because
it's a little bit it's the the one we
have most be most recently in mind I had
to laugh when you talk about one person
can stop the entire process I think
we've heard into the Quaker forms of
deliberation and consensus and I was
thinking about the senator on the
jobless benefits and or not we're not
quite so different I want to
congratulate is very rich in my judgment
ethnographic study a very important
problem in Latin America Royce's
addressing itches in my mind protecting
fragile areas in efforts to build
sustainable tourism which is an
important source of revenue for Latin
America in the future her main interests
in this paper are in the plum of
plumbing of the limits of defining for
us what consensus really means consensus
and this concept of medical census and
how important that is and she does that
by highlighting attention between two
groups los Ticos and loca que dos I
think they must be called but it struck
me a strange that de quoi que tous first
of all what were they doing in Costa
Rica to begin with and second why after
50 years they're still consider getting
goose and I'm wondering whether those
transnationals and the gringos that you
described and you say well they can
always get up and leave I guess we all
have that option to some extent but
really they've created a different song
for a sort of form of community so I
just was wondering why after almost 50
or even 60 years now there is still such
a distinction made on racial ethnic
grounds or national origin that was just
one comment for mean whether those
Gringo's there are really building a
culture marisa that it's difficult to
understand there and it might be also
difficult for those people to come back
here to and something different some
they haven't read it contribute to an
important transnationalism in terms of
the bottom line of the paper what I took
from it maybe it's more of our social
science perspective is how politics
mattered so much at the very end and how
kind of discouraging it all was Maurice
I know your interest was more in the
participation participation at various
groups and consensus-building and so
forth but after all that great work on
the plan nothing really seemed to happen
maybe I was a little discouraged about
that because they required consensus
from the approval from the people who
lived on that impossible mud road hours
away and those people couldn't agree
about the time of day much less on the
plan but I google or so a lot of the
good work and and consensus-building it
seemed to me wasn't going to lead to
very much what does that tell us about
similar efforts elsewhere maybe less
well informed less serious efforts to
protect going back to the main question
protecting fragile areas in an effort to
build sustainable tourism it can't have
been there emerged that can it really
happen anywhere else milena Gomez has
taught us a wonderful case that I
mentioned that already of the diaspora
communities and where her interest is in
housing and housing markets and brought
a wealth of data and I congratulate her
for that it would have passed without
anyone noticing if she hadn't taken the
time to put that data together I guess
though it sets off in my mind maybe two
separate sets of questions milena what
one is this kind of romantic and
nostalgic emotional appeal of what you
call me kiere those who are born there
and by the way the Colombian diaspora it
seems is more of a middle class diaspora
than the Mexican diaspora or the
Salvadoran diaspora or even Ecuador and
the Columbia has sent
in middle class me so the question I
have is what is this something that goes
beyond the romantic and a nostalgic I
mean to those people actually buy those
houses that they actually move in did
their children ever want to go if they
did that they feel at home or do they
prefer to come back to New Jersey or
long island is there such a thing as we
getta ultimately and in the return home
they didn't mean that to sound stark or
melodramatic but it's a question in my
mind and more generally what your paper
rises in my mind and you and I've had
the opportunity talked about this before
is how in Latin American countries see
their expatriate competitors they went
from Poole ignoring them as you point
out milena to see them as aha a source
of remittances to they can even help us
in the construction industry but how is
the Latin American view of these
diaspora communities emerging do they
see them as for example extensions of
Colombian Mexican foreign policy did
they see them of lobbying groups they
they see them as ways to influence this
chaotic American debate on free trade
and migration reform on drug trafficking
and so forth so your case study raises
questions which in my mind which are
very a great interest and and can Latin
American governments even if they want
to use the diaspora communities in this
way can they really do that or once
you've left them and set down roots in
this kind of rootless country of ours
here it is something new been been
created mirian thank you very much for
your paper and cuzco and again allowed
me to relive the past so much i think i
may have mentioned or you know how it
it impacted me personally I think I
mentioned already that that's chidiya
that with the red flag indicating the
teacher never i never did try the
teacher what they told me was the
authentic teacher after they told me how
they made it I never really did try it
but I was another surroundings that i
actually have but i noticed that the the
red teacher sign was out with our all
selling brazilian beer there and what I
think the importance to me and
everything is to me and I may not have
been the best person to interpret this
complex series of papers but to me
meridian is showing us is there really
is a middle ground between global and
local one doesn't need to burn down all
the figuratively the starbucks and close
the McDonald's and so forth as may be as
appealing as that might be that isn't
that probably isn't going to happen
there's ways in which the global and
local can meet and can prosper together
that maybe it's not the right word and
it may be a little simplistic but Cusco
and you're telling can become
cosmopolitan in a sense of absorbing
visitors and values from abroad can meet
the world head-on so to speak without
the need for protective barriers people
that coming in from outside and i just
commented loosely but i thought about it
since you're finished remarks about how
entrepreneurial and energetic the coast
Canio's are not just the ones in
sunglass but the ones who live in
communities throughout the that very
interesting City so I like very much the
that you didn't really get a chance to
develop it how you showed us these three
interrelated interrelated processes you
use a lot of expressions here which are
not natural to me but they're very
meaningful rooted cosmopolitanism
occurring through processes of openness
you call it valuing our own aesthetics
and then spatial commitment but you
illustrated in very interesting ways
John Seto and his bar and Donna cozy
FINA and her arts and crafts and how you
kind of brought those concept alive I
think my comment would be I'd love to
see you think about maybe you've already
done it extending this study of in this
concept of rooted cosmopolitanism to
other locales to be able to generalize
elaborate test
and work out possibly with
anthropologists and other social
scientists this theory of rooted
cosmopolitanism because I think it gives
us a way to get beyond this idea that
all tourist tourism is bad and is to be
resisted and the locals must be
protected there are other defense
mechanisms out there and new things are
being created and your paper helps my
understanding of your paper helped me to
realize that and then Jim thank you
again for your paper and Ipanema it's a
bound to be interesting it struck me in
how those kind of screwball people that
we saw of whom we saw depicted in your
slides not your children of course we
know other people and that other ones
are dressed up in the enacting kind of
crazy and through the passage of time
how that unique mixture of intellectuals
and artists came together they created a
unique personality something more than
my mind and a haight-ashbury or a
Greenwich Village and something uniquely
Brazilian and how they really changed
Brazil I mean I think we owe those
people are get a gratitude the clowning
around hides the fact that they were
doing this in a period of time where
they could easily disappear be taken
from the streets for insulting the
military for sending subversive messages
through the mass media for being too
influenced by foreign ideas of too
critical of foreign ideas you ran risks
in in both directions they changed
Brazil culturally but not by being
passive recipients of American jazz or
the Beatles or James Taylor a cat
stevens or the other groups but taking
that in absorbing it and creating
something uniquely beautiful and
Brazilian which they gave to the rest of
the world I mean of course bossa nova I
also mean cinema novo something very
uniquely uniquely Brazilian came out of
that even the irreverent bondhus Ipanema
were really a challenge to the overly
commercialized and structured scholars
you Sambo which down
so much of the kind of all today so in
which reminded me you didn't I think
mentioned the weird year in your
presentation least I don't remember
you're doing so this cut of
cannibalization colon como cuando esto
SE durmio prancies I think it's one of
the cinema novo movies that the
Brazilians were the myth in Brazil would
be kind of eating up the foreigners and
your haste you're even as you admire
them and want to imitate them by their
superior culture and values you eat him
up in the process in that was sort of a
myth in Brazil hopefully it was myth
maybe it really wasn't something in the
1500s that they were lost in the mists
of time but that's sort of what happens
in Brazil that this is not a if an emo
is not a passive recipient of one
culture it it absorbed foreign culture
created something very new change Brazil
and I think changed the world as well
I'm a appreciative gym for you're seeing
that the only one factor that as again
it's a sort of a social to scientists
take on it that you I welcome your
further thoughts on it is all of this
this didn't take place in a vacuum it
seems you've been named a very neat and
clean to us and of course it is a clean
neighborhood in a beautiful beach and so
forth but as you know it's surrounded by
water Brazil the other vast majority
that seventy percent of the Brazilian
population which wasn't very low income
and lives in squatter favela communities
all around the pen name and how that has
influenced the way Panama developed was
it something that the intellectuals and
artists in Brazil opinion were able to
sort of divorce from their reality as
they focused on political trends on
global culture on creating a Brazilian
culture or was it something that
influenced their way they thought of
themselves and what they thought they
were doing that fact that there was this
kind of silently on the edge of opinion
of these beautiful neighborhoods as as
in every beautiful real neighborhood
there was this intrusion of reality
let's say the really the way the most
Brazilians
which is kind of right there in front of
you how did that if influence them how r
vice versa and if that's a very coherent
question but it's a maybe other actors
and other others involved that you
didn't mention your paper which I think
you certainly have must have interesting
insights on was that five minutes Clara
it was an almost more than five minutes
I'm sorry I'm very sorry I think that we
allow me if people don't have to run off
to class or something that we have ten
minutes we can what we owe it to our
guests if we can oh yes come but kinda
speakers take their spots up here well
where I and let's let's see maybe a show
of hands and we'll try to organize I'm
going to anyone else these will get one
over here and one over there we'll go
from that and quite possibly what I'll
let you do and encourage you to do is
just speak up and have our speakers take
note of various points rather than an
address to an individual speaker
although it may be appropriate for one
or another let's hear the various
comments we'll start here please
thank you very very much for that if I
wasn't a good dad consensus that will
get small request we'll get a few more
comments and then and then reacted I'm
all together please be for Miami's nice
to see that we're above on the ranking
ones ah but I was wondering what may be
explaining that is it that the migrants
in Miami come to Miami with higher
skills and occupy higher positions in
the division of labor or is it that
they're able to save more because cost
of living is lower there or what would
it'll be another alternative explanation
for such difference thank you very much
I could have one or two more comments
please didn't want more people would
like to ask and take advantage yes
please are those new develop areas or
was that you feel or is this new
development is that suburban was land
transformation in that I was just
wondering because in some of for example
in um in some of those cities there was
for a time I think that in the night is
a lot of property that was bought by the
narco industry and some a many housing
was empty right so what has happened
with that housing what has this tape
dawn I mean then they they have but they
have done is to redevelop more area to
not take into account the previous
constructed areas yeah i'll give an
opportunity for one more question it
just one more comment or from the floor
don't be shy yes we got one more over
there just speak up please
Miami reasonably stronger than the other
areas in the US released in New York
have you seen any differences in the
remittances very interesting set of
questions well I've thrown up some
questions or hopefully the one for at
least each of you others are comfortable
sorry most of the director toward Molina
maybe Molina will we'll start with you
and I'm going to have to say then we'll
just come down with any of you have to
control maybe your answers you've got it
may be whether you can answer in just
two minutes but then i'd like to each
each of you two minutes to wrap up maybe
respond to what others have are the
questions abandoned any other further
final thoughts that you have and we'll
call it an afternoon at that point we'll
start with you milena okay with
reference to the question about the
Miami um but the immigrants in Miami
come from a different background from
the immigrants in New York so it's more
about class and economics and education
you have a richer clock you know that we
there's a saying that the the rich in
both I live in miami in the working
class lives in New York so I'm you know
and I've talked to brokers in the fares
and they said that you know they're
offering housing four hundred and thirty
thousand dollars they get they sell in
Miami but they don't even sell one in
New York so it's all about you know the
immigrants coming and we're going to
have different socioeconomic backgrounds
and may go to different places in the US
with reference to the question about new
developments yes they're all new
developments in columbia now
construction doesn't get started until
seventy percent of the apartments or
houses are sold and so those those the
map depicted the new developments that
have started you know they come to the
fairs they haven't built the buildings
yet they sell a cell on unplanned nose
on on you know on ideas and then once
they sell seventy percent of
building Thank construction starts and
the issue of not cause I thought that
was really interesting but I all the
information I got the money isn't isn't
really going through 40 nautical you
know drug dealers apartments because
they wouldn't be channeling the money
from here through the account 1812 of
the of the bank you know it they can
just go and pay cash in Columbia so I
don't think the money is going you know
that type of money's not going through
the central bank with reference to the
question of recession the information
that's available in the banquet at
Bouley guys until 2008 and the middle of
2009 so according to the information at
2008 remittances were still increasing
who knows I just today got an email from
the IDB saying that remittances in Latin
America decreased over the board but I
haven't seen the information from the
bank well everybody got a central back
yet for 2009 but I'm sure it's probably
it kept on increasing but who knows now
and in terms of housing the fares have
done less well in the last year than
they did when it was booming in 2005 and
2006 partly but but the the construction
companies have tried to diversify their
interest if they you know they're no
longer in New York they're selling in
New Jersey now they've opened up a fair
in London sore they're trying to adapt
to the changing realities no thank you
very much for later what he said all
right so why were the Quakers in Costa
Rica to begin with they expatiated from
the United States when we went to war in
World War two and instituted the draft
they are a pacifist society and a number
of them were drafted and when they
refused to go with a job they were
arrested and put in jail and when they
decided that they would simply leave the
United States and settle in Costa Rica
who had coincidentally disbanded their
military
at that time so that's how they ended up
there and with the pass of his community
I hit the question about why our
distinction still made I think it's
really really important to part of the
story of the community and it's in part
because a lot of the Quakers and a lot
of the gringos who have settled in the
area have not chosen any level of
assimilation they're people who have
been living there for 60 or 70 years who
still barely speak Spanish or speak
Spanish with incredibly bad accents I
mean that was one reason why are in the
nickname Lima hate Ghana because I had a
I didn't I don't speak Spanish as well
as a lot of people but I had a more
fluent sounding accent and I had more
natural Latin characteristics and so
people in month over there are very
conscious of that where people have
chosen to intermarry that those
distinctions diminish greatly but there
is a degree of separation that still
maintained and so those distinctions are
very much there in part of the community
and he has this disturbing story about
politics and it is disheartening and
it's something that's applying as
planning's about politics and I mean
that I don't know tells say about it it
is sad and they've worked so hard to try
to protect their habitats in a way that
they wanted to protect it and and now
they're they've have been forced into a
situation where they have to deal with
national politics in a way that they
don't think is beneficial so as soon as
that road is paved reset the road
pavement I don't want to comment on the
road when the road paint when the road
is paved there it'll be overwhelmed Jim
okay okay well um thanks for your
comments two things that I would want to
respond to so the thing about
cannibalism this was actually in the
paper that I wrote but this is this is a
long story and persona 1920s personally
intellectuals we're talking about
absorbing foreign art as cannibalism and
then caetano veloso and the tropicals
movement very explicitly talked about
this
as a metaphor for how they were
absorbing the Beatles and things like
that so I meant to make that point I
thank you for making for the second
point this is a very serious point about
about the contradictions as people like
this and Brazil which get the fish gee
that you say yeah yeah and this get a
fish triva was was was criticized for
being silly when there were serious
issues to be to be held and there is a
certain hypocrisy here these people why
this is this is an enclave neighborhood
and these people were living in a bubble
like you people you've been able to live
in a bubble today and they try in many
ways try to ignore the poverty but they
it's sort of a liberal what we would
call liberal today we're generally they
are concerned about the poor and would
like to improve things but when push
comes to shove they defend they defend
himself defend their territories but but
this group certainly was was concerned
about the poor borrowed a lot of
traditions from favelas Samba music and
and of course Carnival has a deep roots
in in poor communities but but i would
say in practice the poor are largely
excluded from the beach and i've written
in great detail about that yeah the the
hypocrisy is that part of the discourse
about the beach is that its democratic
space and everyone is it's open to
everyone at the cape and I figure I've
written in detail about how people are
excluded in the beach actually in
practice so that's a good point I just
didn't quite know how to do this paper
thank you very much Jim and then media
um but let me respond to your comment
first up yes what I'm trying to dress as
some of those intersections as I was
saying that the multiplicity of the
space or the convergence and yes i do
want to understand some of those
intersections in other places in my own
planning practice right now in San
Francisco I feel like we're going
through a process of displacement in
some form of Risa gregation and one of
the crucial elements to understand is
how can we address the planning of some
of these neighborhoods where we can
attract when we can where we can
recognize and accept and assume some
level of diversity and I feel like in
this panel in the previous one there's a
lot of substance that can help us inform
some of the frameworks that one could
use to engage in the development of
neighborhoods in terms of thus the
question thank you for the question it's
a complicated question that I don't know
if I can respond I would like to give it
a try and then follow up over a glass of
wine maybe the queer places and
sexuality those are conflict dimensions
but I find that fascinating not just in
terms of the actual sexual act or
practice but in the way that relates and
expressed to the rest of the society in
the neighborhoods on one level let me
see if I can respond at two levels on
one level of the literature on queer
spaces and the way it is in acting in
the examples that I show you that the
fact that places can be recognized for
again their multiplicity it can be open
and can be challenged I find extremely
useful to understand our development
processes and again confront some of the
tensions or obstacles that we have also
the in terms of then let me address in
terms of that
changes in sexuality and changes in the
spatial practices as I was hearing my
colleagues here at the table 1 sexuality
is it's a serious dimension in the city
on one hand as we know that kind of
Catholic religion imposes a number of
frameworks and points of reference that
on one hand imposes a certain behavior
and on the other hand a kind of
recognizes different forms of sexuality
and relationships and in the case of of
Cusco we have a constant tension between
a very conservative sector of the
population and then a sector of the
population that is very open and engage
the reference that she made about
Bridget Oh Richard is it it's a
profession that people take very
respectfully and careful disser
primarily male although more and more
females are assuming this role to who
assume a very indigenous identity even
if they were not used to long hair they
you know they use long hair and dressing
a certain way and engage with a tourist
ladies or foreign ladies who want to
engage in a relationship but this is
kind of to travel around to enjoy the
place they develop short term
relationships and that's a start that's
kind of in between a lifestyle and a
business so bridge shadows are important
figures of the city you can find them at
bars of the plaza and that expresses
kind of one particular form of sexuality
at the core of tourism in in Cusco now
in this tension between the more formal
and traditional side and the more open
it doesn't go without come to station
when andreas unica returned to cusco he
he had to deal with the police in order
to open his places many of his customers
run into trouble and violent attacks but
there
is still an effort to create those
respectful spaces those safe spaces for
a population that had been discriminated
and continues to be discriminated one
important piece that I think relates to
some of the planning processes that
we're talking about is that couscous in
the coast in your community is not
afraid of fights fights are part of the
process so if you are attacked because
you're queer that doesn't stop you that
doesn't prevent you from continuing a
particular social practice that you want
to engage with similarly in the planning
processes that go on in Cuzco people are
not afraid of confrontation and they can
yell at each other and then go and have
a drink so I think that becomes an
important element in kind of
acknowledging the diversity and the mix
that is possible with the city of Cuzco
and the rest is over the glass of wine
that you're going to have I think it's
wonderful I want to
Mary the time when motto I'm not sure
but it was nine o'clock